[Música]
los dos aspirantes a la presidencia de
Brasil cruzaron Reproches ayer en un
último debate de Cara a la segunda
vuelta de mañana el izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva y el actual
mandatario ultraconservador Yair
bolsonaro se acusaron mutuamente de
mentir la economía la pandemia y el
aborto fueron temas centrales
Rusia acusó al Reino Unido de ayudar a
Ucrania a planear el ataque con drones
sobre la Bahía de sebastopol El más
masivo en la Península de crimea desde
el inicio del conflicto según las
autoridades locales además
Moscú señaló la implicación de expertos
de la Marina británica en las
explosiones de los gasoductos nordstream
en el mar Báltico
la guardia Revolucionaria de Irán
advirtió a los manifestantes no salir a
las calles asegurando que hoy es el
último día de disturbios una amenaza
tras la intensificación de las protestas
desde que el miércoles se cumplieran 40
días de la muerte de maxa aminid bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral
conectamos
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
de Brasil porque los dos aspirantes a la
presidencia del país se enfrentaron ayer
en un último debate que fue televisado
por la cadena globo el izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva y el actual
mandatario ultraconservador Yair
bolsonaro se cruzaron Reproches acerca
de los respectivos mandatos los temas
abordados fueron desde la corrupción
hasta el aborto Marina sardina con los
detalles
un último intenso cara a cara previa la
segunda vuelta electoral de las
presidenciales brasileñas a la izquierda
el ex presidente Luis Ignacio lulada
Silva quien lidera los sondeos con 6
puntos de ventaja a la derecha su rival
el mandatario Yair bolsonaro quien Busca
la reelección
la violencia conmigo disminuyó mucho en
tu gobierno solo subió desde que
asumiste en 2003 hasta 2006 aumentaron
de media un 30% los homicidios en Brasil
que hicimos nosotros para revertir eso
al contrario que tú Yo no fui a visitar
a traficantes
por armas de fuego armas portadas por
bandidos y no por ciudadanos de bien
y del otro lado de la pantalla una
nación altamente polarizada algo que
sabía en ambos candidatos que durante el
debate se lanzaron constantes ataques
directos y acusaciones desacreditándose
en mi gobierno va a hacer lo siguiente
vamos a pedir autorización a las fuerzas
armadas y vamos a fisca porque el crimen
organizado no puede en nombre de la
liberalización de armas estar haciéndose
con un Arsenal más competente que el de
la policía
pese a esto algunos de los temas
tratados fueron desde la corrupción las
relaciones políticas con otras naciones
la economía interna hasta las tasas de
pobreza de Brasil los analistas
señalaban que este debate es crucial
para esa gran parte del electorado que
todavía se considera como indecisos el
55% de los brasileños afirman que la
televisada contienda es muy importante
para su decisión una respuesta que la
cuarta democracia más grande del mundo
sabrá el domingo
en otras noticias la policía de San
Francisco determinó que el ataque al
esposo de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos Nancy
pelosi fue intencional el ataque tuvo
lugar ayer viernes por la mañana cuando
un hombre entró en la residencia de Paul
pelosi de 82 años buscando a su mujer
Nancy pelosi la persona con el hacer
cargo político más importante de Estados
Unidos El asalto Aviva los temores de
violencia política a diez días de las
elecciones legislativas de medio término
Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
un ataque intencional así calificó la
policía de San Francisco la agresión
sufrida por el esposo de la presidenta
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos Nancy
pelosigation basados en nuestra
investigación en este momento sabemos
que esto no fue un acto al azar fue
intencional y está mal
pelosi de 82 años Fue embestido a
martillazos en su casa por un intruso
las heridas de la víctima fueron
significativas pero sí fue llevado un
hospital local donde fue intervenido por
una fractura de cráneo además de
presentar lesiones en el brazo derecho
la plana mayor demócrata no tardó en
reaccionar
ya es suficiente ya es suficiente toda
persona de buena conciencia debió
ponerse claramente y sin ambigüedades a
la violencia en nuestra política
independientemente de cuáles sean sus
políticas
el presidente reiteró que la frase del
atacante que Preguntaba dónde está Nancy
también se escuchó en los pasillos del
Capitolio durante la toma del 6 de enero
de 2021 la vicepresidenta Harris
calificó el suceso como un hecho por
debajo de la dignidad y la inteligencia
de los estadounidenses
Esto fue un acto de extrema violencia y
creo que estamos viendo un momento en
nuestro país donde hay un discurso muy
alimentado por el odio y la división
[Música]
el estado actual de polpelos y es
prometedor los médicos afirmaron que el
tratamiento a sus heridas fue exitoso y
esperan una recuperación completa El
asalto se dio en un contexto electoral
avivando así los temores de violencia
política Estados Unidos se encuentra a
días de las elecciones de medio término
que decidirá Cuál de los dos grandes
partidos se hace con el control del
congreso
y justamente el gobierno de Estados
Unidos emitió un comunicado a las
fuerzas del orden Público advirtiendo de
los riesgos de violencia de Cara a las
elecciones de medio término que se
celebrarán recordemos el próximo 8 de
noviembre desde Washington nos amplía
nuestro corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez
el gobierno de Estados Unidos emitió un
comunicado de alerta mayor de violencia
antes de las elecciones de mitad de
término impulsadas por un aumento en el
extremismo doméstico esto según un
documento publicado conjuntamente por el
FBI el departamento de seguridad
nacional y la policía del Capitolio y
también el Centro Nacional de contra
terrorismo en este comunicado se dice
que los objetivos potenciales de esta
alerta mayor de violencia son candidatos
que se postulan a cargos públicos
funcionarios electorales personas que
participan en eventos políticos y
representantes de partidos así también
como minorías raciales y religiosas
según los oficiales de inteligencia La
amenaza más posible antes del día de las
elecciones vendrá de delincuentes
solitarios o lobos solitarios que
aprovechaban aprovecharán los problemas
relacionados con las elecciones para
justificar la violencia de hecho estos
agentes del gobierno agregan que muchas
de estas personas a un amplifican estas
narrativas falsas de fraude electoral
que se remontan al 2020 el informe se
emitió precisamente el día en que el
esposo de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi fue atacado
violentamente por un hombre que entró a
la residencia a la congresista en San
Francisco gritando donde está Nancy
Dónde está Nancy pelosi el viernes
También el departamento de justicia de
Estados Unidos anunció que un hombre de
Pensilvania había sido declarado
culpable de múltiples amenazas por hacer
múltiples amenazas de muerte contra
congresistas
vamos ahora con información relacionada
con la guerra en Ucrania porque la
Marina rusa informó que logró repeler un
supuesto ataque ucraniano con drones
sobre la Bahía de sebastopol en el mar
Negro donde se ubica la base de las
fuerzas navales rusas
Moscú calificó de terroristas los
presuntos ataques contra buques que
supuestamente están encargados de
garantizar la seguridad del corredor
para la exportación de trigo ucraniano
desde el mar Negro Rusia acusó además a
Reino Unido de haber ayudado a Ucrania a
planear el ataque contra el puerto de
sebastopol en la Península de crimea
territorios que
Moscú considera como propios tras
anexionarlos ilegalmente en 2014 por
otro lado el kremlin también acusa a
Londres de estar implicado en la
explosión de los gasoductos nordstream
en el mar Báltico en septiembre
[Música]
cabe subrayar que los barcos de la flota
del mar Negro que sufrieron un ataque
terrorista participaron en la seguridad
de un corredor de cereales como parte de
una iniciativa internacional para
exportar productos agrícolas desde los
puertos ucranianos la preparación de
este acto terrorista y el entrenamiento
del personal militar del centro especial
de operaciones marítimas de Ucrania 73
fue dirigido por especialistas
británicos con base en ochaquive la
región de nikolai de Ucrania según la
información disponible representantes De
esta unidad de la armada británica
participaron en la planificación
provisión e implementación de un ataque
terrorista en el mar Báltico el 26 de
septiembre de este año la voladura de
los gasoductos nord Stream 1 y North
Stream 2
cambiamos de información en Irán el
comandante de la guardia Revolucionaria
José salami amenazó a los manifestantes
que hoy sería el último día de protestas
recordemos que la muerte de maxa a
Minnie el 16 de septiembre bajo custodia
de la policía de la moral desató un
movimiento masivo contra las autoridades
de Teherán y que según distintas ong de
Derechos Humanos la fuerza pública ha
matado a más de 200 personas en el marco
de la represión de las protestas
conectamos ahora con nuestra
corresponsal en Irán Catalina Gómez
Ángel Catalina buenos días Qué significa
esta amenaza de la guardia
Revolucionaria hasta donde más se puede
llegar a la represión y se espera que
pueda acabar con las protestas
Esa no es la primera Obviamente el
General José insalam es la máxima figura
los guardias revolucionarios pero no es
la primera vez que desde esta
institución y de otras instituciones de
la república islámica se da por sentado
que las protestas no van a seguir
existiendo en el mismo momento que él
daba esas declaraciones en la ciudad de
chiradas en el sur occidente del país en
ese funeral en el cual se conmemoraba y
se recordaba a esas 15 personas
fallecidas en el atentado proclamado por
Isis el pasado miércoles a esta misma
hora se llevaban a cabo protestas no
solamente en varias universidades de
Teherán sino en otras ciudades más
pequeñas del país y esto se daba por
diferentes motivos porque habían sido
atacado los médicos en algunas
universidades porque los estudiantes no
creen la versión de la República
islámica de que el atentado en chiras
haya sido llevado por el estado islámico
discurso incluso acusan a las mismas
autoridades o también en algunos
funerales de personas que murieron
durante el fin de semana Así que hay que
esperar es muy probable que todos se
termine con esta proclamación de del
General salami pero habrá que verlo las
próximas días
Por supuesto continuaremos muy
pendientes de esto Catalina Pero por
otro lado las autoridades de la
República islámica acusaron hoy también
a las periodistas que revelaron la
muerte de amini y que cubrieron a su
funeral momento en que empezaron las
protestas de haber sido entrenadas por
la Cia porque esta nueva acusación de
injerencia extranjera Y qué se sabe del
estado de las periodistas
la República islámica ha acusado a
Estados Unidos a lo que llaman el estado
sionista a Gran Bretaña y Arabia Saudita
está detrás de estas protestas y no
solamente estar detrás sino estar
promocionando Muchos medios que operan
desde el extranjero en lengua persa y
que estarían también según ellos
motivando estas protestas estas dos
periodistas son bastante reconocidas en
el país es dedicadas a temas sociales y
ella se dedicaron no solamente a contar
la historia de masa a mí el día que fue
llevada a la clínica sino también en
dejar estuvo en la ciudad donde fue
enterrada y son reconocidísimas hasta el
punto que muchos periodistas dicen hoy
que ellas no necesitan ser entrenadas
por ninguna fuerza de seguridad
extranjera para saber cuál es su trabajo
y esta preocupación de estas acusaciones
son bastante graves porque la hacen
conjuntamente tanto el Ministerio de
inteligencia como el departamento de
inteligencia de los guardias
revolucionarios que generalmente no
suelen trabajar juntos Así que preocupa
la seguridad de estas mujeres que
bienvenidas están en la cárcel por
muchos días estuvieron en Solitarios en
sus celdas han podido llamar a sus
esposos pero al día de hoy no han tenido
ningún juicio y no se sabe realmente de
que las acusan Catalina Muchísimas
gracias por su reporte sin duda como
decíamos muy pendientes de la evolución
de la situación en Irán
y este martes Israel vota en sus quintas
elecciones parlamentarias en dos años y
medio aún sin certezas sobre quién
podría liderar un futuro gobierno las
últimas encuestas divulgadas por medios
nacionales dan la delantera al bloque
del ex Primer Ministro Benjamin netan
Yahoo que sin embargo no alcanzaría los
61 escaños necesarios para asegurar la
mayoría nos informa nuestro corresponsal
en Jerusalén Federico Cuevas verena
las últimas encuestas antes de las
elecciones israelíes de este primero de
noviembre arrojan la misma conclusión
nadie tiene la mayoría asegurada sin
embargo el bloque alineado con el hecho
de Primer Ministro Benjamin etaniau
tendría las mejores posibilidades los
sondeos de cuatro medios y relieves lo
ubican con 60 escaños uno por debajo de
los necesarios para volver a gobernar
poco más de un año después de su salida
y en medio de un juicio por varios
cargos de corrupción la alianza
antidetaniaco hoy en El Ejecutivo
liderado por Yahir rapid alcanzaría 56 y
los socios árabes hadas Talk que
rechazan ambos bandos cruzarían el
umbral con cuatro del oso de sondeo se
desprende un ascenso de la extrema
derecha representada por sionismo
religioso una alianza con posiciones
racistas y homófobas que sería el Aliado
clave de netanago del otro lado los
partidos de izquierda laborista y medett
se encaminan a mínimos históricos Aunque
suficientes para no quedarse fuera del
parlamento de nuevo la ecuación de estos
comicios se puede depender del terremoto
de La minoría árabe en gran medida
desilusionada porque incluso con la
presencia del islamista Ram en el
gobierno de lapid se mantiene como el
sector más empobrecido y violentado de
la sociedad israelí así se acerca al
final de una campaña agresiva enfocada
en el alto costo de vida y la seguridad
y muy alejada del conflicto israelí
palestino si la nueva que necesita que
se vislumbra más derechista que nunca no
logra romper el estancamiento político
Israel se enfrentaría a unas posibles
sextas elecciones en sólo tres años
Muchísimas gracias por su atención
enseguida volvemos
[Música]